for the past three weeks
hundreds of indigenous protesters have
been camping in the heart of the capital
brasilia
they've come from all over brazil even
the most remote villages of the amazon
the plan was to unite more than 40
indigenous peoples
and to stop congress from approving a
controversial bill
backed by the powerful farm lobby and
president jair bolsonaro himself
brazil bolsonaro has said he will not
set aside a single centimeter of
indigenous reservations
since his inauguration several attempts
have been made to limit our rights to
claim our territories
among them a bill barring recognition of
ancestral lands which were not occupied
by 1988
when brazil's democratic constitution
was approved
indigenous leaders say that fixing a
cut-off date violates their
constitutional rights
the bill doesn't take into account that
many were violently expelled from their
lands
before 1988
we fought for our rights when the
constitution was being drafted we will
fight against those who want to override
our constitutional rights
the protesters were hoping the supreme
court would rule that the bill violates
the constitution
the decision was expected this week
but at the last minute it was postponed
until august
leaving many here frustrated but
undefeated
these indigenous protesters are already
packing their bags to leave brasilia but
they
say this is not their last supper they
will return in august
to fight for their rights yanakiv
al-jazeera brasilia